well welcome to our first ever tea from
22 video from The Spectator where we
will interview a fascinating Westminster
figure every week
I'm Isabelle Hardman and I edit the
coffee house blog and today I'm joined
by Margo is rising Tory star PPS Lord
green and member of the number-10 Policy
Board so Margo the number-10 Policy
Board is quite a mysterious entity at
the moment and I wondered if you could
tell us a little bit about how it works
how often you meet yes we meet about
once a month and periodically we'll meet
with the prime minister and we basically
go through very very top-line a series
of policy proposals that each of us have
either developed ourselves or have had
proposed to us by other conservative MPs
and we probably present these ideas in
about two minutes oh well yes it's got
to be very top line and how many
policies are there that are in the
pipeline that is being really considered
seriously because I think the board's
only had one policy that's actually made
it into the public domain so far that
the impression I get is that there's
only been one announcement on the
private rented sector that was a policy
book yeah okay I was trained as a policy
board analysis yes that's true too yes
that was a policy port idea and there
has been another one as well have you
got any particular ideas that you want
sir I've got actually this time my I
worked on an idea with Jesse Norman on
the old area of town center development
and in you know improvement and you've
mentioned Jesse Norman a couple of times
obviously he's left the policy board now
one of the things that has been going
around Westminster as a rumor is that
the policy grief and I know it's changed
since the reshuffle hasn't been getting
on that well that hasn't really been a
sense that the members have gelled that
well would you disagree with that no no
I hadn't even heard that rumor actually
no I certainly don't agree with that in
fact there's been quite a momentum and
the last few board meetings have been
you know we've all been quite galvanized
do you feel able to disagree with one
another because
yes different parts of the party on you
yes yes well exactly and some we
certainly do yes yeah
has it ever got heated not in a
disagreeable sense no I mean I put an
idea forward at the last meeting and one
of my colleagues just said look I think
that's a really good idea but I think
it's really bad politics because you're
able to be honest yeah Mogi there was a
point where you resigned from the
Conservative Party back in the day I
wonder whether you could tell us a
little bit about that what why did you
feel the need to leave and when I left
the day after mrs. Thatcher's for
starters as Prime Minister why was that
I was so angry about the hair removal I
was I'm still I can i still feel the
anger now 20 years later I felt it was
an absolute act of treachery and
disloyalty one thing that you've been a
real cheerleader for is is the
modernization project at the
Conservative Party you and a huge amount
of praise for your contributions to the
gay marriage debate for instance and I
was interested in how successful you
think modernization has been how much
more needs to be done I think quite a
lot more needs to be done actually I
think it's very much a job half done at
the moment do you think the gay marriage
law obviously it's it's now an act but
the way the debate was conducted in the
party do you think that has benefited
the party's image or damaged it I think
that what people left with is that it is
a conservative-led government and a
conservative prime minister that has got
gay marriage on the statute book what
about some of the contributions aside
your colleagues when we were at the
second reading I did get quite incensed
with some of my colleagues who were sort
of bearing the Secretary of State who
was trying to make their you know the
opening speech and I thought that was a
bit much and it did get me angry which
is why I spoke quite passionately when
my when I was finally called but on the
whole I think the debate was carried out
in quite a good spirit in Parliament
sadly that can't be you know said of
some of the rest of the country where
some of the evangelical groups
deliberately
mislead the public to believe that we
were trying to force gay marriages in
churches which almost source Indigo's
which we were never doing and they knew
that all along so I think it was really
appalling the way that behaved there was
a wider attempt to say confusion yes I
think so but I think in Parliament it
was it was okay okay well thank you so
much Margaux for talking to us on our
first ever tea from 22 film we'll be
back to talk to another fascinating
guest from Westminster so do join us
then